kyle and the liberal mind that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now the reaction to the kyle rittenhouse
trial and tucker's interview with him it
got me thinking
now liberals used to believe in more not
less speech and they were defenders of
the first amendment and the rights of
defendants now they were suspicious of
overzealous prosecutors and they were
wary of elites who pretended to care
about the downtrodden but really didn't
they believed in a color-blind society
all good stuff
but now they flipped on so many fronts
the new liberals are actually illiberal
they lose all sense of logic where
politics is concerned they're among the
most close-minded intolerant people
you'll ever encounter
they dis-invite conservative relatives
from weddings and bar mitzvahs heck if
you voted for trump they nixed you from
the holiday party list long ago
now in our schools they refuse to teach
the great works of western civilization
all racist of course they reject
american history because it's filled
with white privilege don't you know and
for them our nation should forever be
defined by two things
slavery and oppression
and they just refuse to think about
anything that disrupts this rigid world
view
like for instance like why did president
eisenhower have a portrait of robert e
lee in the oval office
and why in human biology are there only
two sexes
and what if jacob blake michael brown
and george floyd hadn't resisted their
arrests
and if rittenhouse didn't deserve the
right to self-defense
who does
but they instead stay inside their own
cocoon no tough questions no
hypotheticals no independent thought
certainly no critical thinking
just ranting
to make a hero
of written house is appalling and
disgraceful right folks you will not be
spared because the victims of kylo ren
house were white the kyle written house
verdict an acquittal being cheered by
the far right even as it strikes fear in
the hearts of communities of color
all of this was unfair and untrue
he's not only not a racist
the only thing that kyle rittenhouse
seems biased against are riots
i'm not a racist person i support the
blm movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how
how much a prosecutor can take advantage
of somebody like if they did this to me
imagine what they could have done to a
person of color who doesn't maybe have
the resources i do or is not widely
publicized like my case
absolutely right great points
and by the way this jury was not corrupt
applying law and facts hearing testimony
including kyle's
they acquitted him on all counts
but the modern left doesn't care instead
it's slash and burn at the stake
excuses in the world
does not change the fact
that three people got shot yeah two
people were murdered to me it's murder
i'm sorry
now compare their hyperbole and hysteria
to the words of the 18 year old whose
life they hope to shatter
his words to joe biden who suggested by
the way he was a white supremacist here
they are
mr president if i could say one thing to
you i would urge you to go back and
watch the trial
and understand the facts before you make
a statement it's
it's actual malice defaming my character
for him to say something like that
it's actually quite hysterical
how nobody can go back and look at the
facts of the case and the lies that they
can just get away with spreading
although i wouldn't have wanted my own
son my own teenage son to rush into a
riot like kyle did armed or not
most moms wouldn't rittenhouse really
impressed me in this interview with
tucker
he was more poised and more
knowledgeable about the constitution
than any member of the squad and
certainly more sincere than
let's say our current speaker of the
house
the right thing to do would be to turn
myself in i didn't do anything wrong
it's obvious self-defense this wasn't a
political case it shouldn't have been a
political case it was made a political
case this had nothing to do with race
and the the ways people are twisting
this it's just sickening
he's right of course this was never
about politics but the left desperately
needed it to be
they wanted to make an example out of
kyle
they know that an armed citizenry is the
last defense to the soft tyranny that
many of them actually prefer to
democracy
you see for them it can't be that kyle
rittenhouse is innocent instead they
reflexively build up the kitty rapists
and domestic abusers who were rioting
that night as mythical figures
they were selfless heroes they practiced
they could have saved they could have
saved dozens of lives i would never jump
in front of a guy with an ar-15 strap
down
and so they were heroes and i'm sick and
tired of everybody making like they you
know like they deserve to die they were
unbelievably brave courageous individual
individuals
now what happened to thinking for
ourselves or are we so trapped in our
own bubbles that we lose sight of
thinking independently
there's a world beyond twitter and
instagram and constant protest at some
point
we all need to grow up
we already have too many infantilized
adults who are afraid of asking
questions or frankly afraid of recognize
recognizing the truths that are right in
front of them
now contrary to what the regime media
would have you believe
conservatives are actually today's
rebels especially on college campuses
conservatives still question authority
when appropriate
like when dr fauci tries to tell us that
well they try to tell us which relatives
are safe to see this thanksgiving
we don't blindly follow the
pronouncements of celebrities like colin
kaepernick we don't assume the worst in
people because of their skin color like
so many on the left did with kyle
rittenhouse
yet their default position is to
demonize smart and thoughtful people who
disagree with them
they hate aaron rodgers because he
thinks for himself and a woman like
winsome spears here's
who they think isn't really black
because she doesn't worship big
government
and by the way this intellectual decay
didn't happen overnight it occurred over
decades
with liberals subverting the
institutions that traditionally nurtured
both critical thinking skills
and a love of country
turning them all into kind of cheap
propaganda outlets
they produce graduates who've never been
tested frankly they've never even been
held accountable
so of course they wither under real
questioning in june um you suggested
that defenders of the filibuster
are motivated at least in part by racism
do you still feel that way i mean it's
just what i'd look at history use of the
filibuster seems to be triggered in in
points like this where it is about
uplifting black folks in our country
and protecting them
that makes no sense certainly not in
recent history of course we also have
big city mayors who play the victim
while their policies victimize the most
disadvantaged
there is violence and there is
destruction what's your message to the
people on the streets tonight
my message is you've been heard thank
you for calling out the administration
for what it's doing it's
unconstitutional it's an affront to
democracy
or even worse a vice president with a
law degree who's so in over her head
that she makes joe biden look capable
what else are you going to do to fix
this problem with inflation well let's
start with this
prices have gone up is on a daily level
something that is a heavy weight to
carry so it is something that we take
very seriously
oh my gosh she's just an embarrassment
to liberals everywhere i mean this is
the best your movement can produce
time to rethink your plan people
america thrives when we reward those of
all colors and backgrounds who are
hard-working capable and independent
instead of rewarding those who spend
their waking hours waiting for the world
to come to them to their rescue and all
the while complaining about how unfair
the world is how unfair life is
and we also need dedicated public
servants who understand that if they
refuse to protect the public safety
the public will have to protect
themselves
it's time to demand better of ourselves
and of those we elect to office
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else